[Música]
hace unos meses fue una fiesta
era en la casa de un chico de la escuela
y fui unos amigos de la división a ver
que anda la fiesta estaba buena había
buena música no había demasiada luz y
conocía bastante gente era un lindo
ambiente
al rato nos acercamos a hablar con unos
conocidos de mis amigos y violín que me
gustó
me presté mucha atención al principio
pero pues me acerqué a hablar porque era
la única persona que no conocía nadie me
atrajo su buena onda y facilidad para
sacar temas de conversación y pasamos
juntos lo que queda de la fiesta la
persona que conocí era juan
esa noche cuando volví a mi casa y una
ensalada que nunca antes me había pasado
esto de relacionarme con un chico
yo cuando viene a fiesta no voy pensando
con quién me voy a relacionar
sino lo que busco es pasarla bien y
disfrutar
sin embargo no pensé que me podría
llegar a gustar porque no era típico
para mí iba en contra de lo que me salía
naturalmente
también esa noche tenía varias preguntas
en mi cabeza no como por ejemplo cuáles
son los criterios que tenemos en cuenta
al momento de terminar si nos gusta bien
o no su físico su género su personalidad
una combinación de características
tampoco tenía muy en claro porque me
estaba haciendo estas preguntas sí con
cosas bastantes similares y estas dudas
no tenían lugar porque una vía de
respuesta a ellas hop porque me gustan
tanto de las milanesas eso se notan y
listo
toda esta situación preguntas respuestas
yo pensar en dos cosas
la primera porque tenemos la necesidad
de encasillar a las personas en cuanto a
su físico su género su personalidad su
intelecto segundo cómo es que nos llega
a gustar a alguien por estas cualidades
no lo tengo muy claro pero creo que
funcionamos con una especie de filtros
que van marcando lo bueno y lo malo de
una persona respecto a nuestro criterio
concluir después de mucho tiempo que ese
criterio para mí era simplemente si me
gustaba a su persona y si me sentía
cómodo a su lado
no importaba quién es esa persona
tampoco importaba aquí le gustaba si era
hombre en mujer
o lo que sea si esa persona ha gustado
de mí y yo gusta a esa persona no había
nada más por qué preocuparse
veo a la orientación sexual no como un
género de preferencia sino al conjunto
de filtros con el que cada uno elige
no existe para mí tal cosa como ser gay
heterosexual
pan sexual bisexual
porque el concepto de género
no lo entiendo
entiendo qué es lo que te hace hombre o
qué es lo que te hace mujer por lo tanto
tampoco entiendo tu sexualidad cómo se
la suele conocer aunque sigue siendo
difícil para nosotros determinar
nuestros gustos y eso por qué
porque la idea del amor en este sistema
social en el que vivimos y nos
relacionamos es tal casa 230 una
relación monogámica con una pareja de tu
sexo opuesto con dos hijos un hijo mayor
una hija menor
eso es lo que se nos inculca consciente
e inconscientemente a cada uno de
nosotros
y no seguir lo que profundamente a cada
uno nos gusta
estos filtros fueron cambiados
modificados e incluso flexibilizados
gracias a que tuvieron en lugar de ser
replanteados a lo largo de la historia
creo que vivimos en un momento muy
particular en el que existe no sólo un
replanteo amplio sino profundo de estos
filtros
y también la disminución de aquellos que
fueron impuestos por alguien más además
de ustedes mismos
lo veo todos los días en la calle en las
marchas
en la escuela y eso es algo buenísimo
porque cada vez somos más los que
pensamos así
y eso es una continuación por una lucha
por el libre derecho de la expresión
sexual ya mí me pasa esto yo el filtro
género no lo tengo presente
y puede que de acá a cinco diez veinte
años no tengan muchas más personas
si este filtro no existiese en la cabeza
de nadie más
entonces problemas actuales graves no
tendrían lugar como la discriminación la
desigualdad y la inequidad de derechos
por ser quién sos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]